we couldn't really do a MIDI video
without having an old keyboard from the
80s and there's nothing more iconic I
think from the 80s than Yamaha dx7 it's
got those classic piano sounds and stuff
let me find an organ there was a hospice
a classic I mean that they're pretty
awful sounds I'm not a keyboard player
but I think that was part of the
advantage of MIDI is as someone that
wasn't a great player and didn't know a
lot about sounds you could just worry
about it later
fix it change the sounds later on so the
scope was much more than them with audio
but yeah the sounds were bad then the
sounds are bad what can you do
MIDI was something that was designed in
the early eighties it came out in 1983
but there were earlier versions of it
made by roland which kind of prototypes
that became midi and i'd say it's kind
of analogous in some ways to like a
compression algorithm it's very loosely
analogous so instead of say having a
bass drum that's recorded as an audio
signal so you've got a microphone inside
the bass drum and you're playing the
bass drum and it would take up a lot of
back in those days I mean you weren't
even really thinking about disk space
because it wasn't being recorded
digitally but if it had a being it would
have taken up a lot of disk space more
than was possible to do what you could
do is you could get one of the bass
drums and say well all the bass drum
sounds are basically the same thing what
we do is we'll store that one sound and
then play a note on a keyboard or play a
note from a trigger or from a computer
or something like that and it would play
that sound over and over again and that
was one of the many many uses of MIDI
but it was the idea that you control
your devices in the studio by little
bits of information rather than
containing the whole wave or whatever do
you wanna do
Middies an acronym isn't it is yeah it
stands for musical instrument digital
interface midi obviously ended up being
used with computers very very early on
atari the st model and i think a lot of
other models had MIDI ports directly in
on the side and because they had a
graphical environment
Steinberg wrote Cubase I believe it was
still it was Steinberg back then they
wrote a piece of software called Cubase
which was an early MIDI sequencer which
is still going today today as a
full-blown audio and MIDI package in
fact we're probably end up using that a
bit later but back in those days you
could effectively create a whole
composition on a computer and trigger
off the sounds from various of sound
modules and samplers and whatever else
and and it would produce these files
that were maybe a captain of K in size
but could have a whole arrangement which
back in those days was was phenomenal so
let's get into a bit more technical
stuff in MIDI there's these things
called channels so there's 16 channels
which are from the users point of view
numbered 1 to 16 but internally 0 to 15
for obvious reasons and they basically
you could see a channel as as a way of
addressing different pieces of equipment
and there's also a mode called Omni
which means it would listen to all
channels so if you wanted to say have a
piece of equipment that had that just
did the piano another piece of equipment
that just did the drums another one that
just did the bass you could set them to
different channel numbers internally you
could go to their settings as I only
want to listen to channel 3 on this
particular piece of equipment and then
you could have different tracks within
your MIDI sequencer that would only put
that data to channel 3 and only put that
data to channel 1 let's say so you could
have effectively one signal that would
carry all the data for the entire song
this is like one set of cabling that
perhaps all connected to all of the
equipment would yeah I mean the way
I mean there's this all sorts of
complicated ways of cabling up MIDI with
distribution boxes but the the most
simple way to do it would be to go out
of your computer or your sequencer or
whatever into your keyboard and then out
of the keyboard out of that one to the
next one or should mention at this point
the actual MIDI the look of MIDI cables
so I mean this is the back of a focus
right stereo sound card here so as you
can see the the standard MIDI in and out
are the 5-pin din sockets similar to the
socket that was used on a tape machine
to put programs into an old computer
like my old icon lecture on BBC so we've
linked all these machines together so so
one let's let's strip it down because
it's all very well to say there's 16
channels as with anything it's better to
explain it simplified so let's forget
the fact there's 16 channels and just go
with one channel so let's say we've got
a keyboard and a piano module and that's
all we're dealing with and there are
five types of messages that you get that
MIDI can transmit and receive and the
first of which which is probably the
most used are what's called the channel
voice signals and the channel voice
signals are very similar to cable
signals from a computer keyboard or
anything else and if you've ever done
any programming or sort of dealt with
anything events in JavaScript or
something like that you'd know that
there's sort of Mouse down mouse up
events keydown keyup events and you get
the same thing with keyboards so the
channel voice settings will say on
channel 1 I'm going to send a note down
and then a note up so you can record the
length of the time that the note was
down you can also on some cables with
aftertouch say how much pressure yeah
how much pressure you're applying after
the event you can say how much pressure
you initially touched it with the volume
of the note and a whole host of other
things like the modulation wheel and
you've then got after that channel mode
signals which I'm not going to go into
but they're just basic satellite little
reset signals and system signals and
stuff like
and then you've got what's called a
system common messages which are things
that are sent to every device in the
system so if you had a whole load of
sound modules it send it to all of them
and then you've got system real-time
signals which are things like your time
code in your clock all that kind of
stuff and then you've got what's called
system exclusive signals or see sex as
they're called for short which is
slightly a backup and restore can be
used for backup and restore
functionality so let's say you've got a
sound module and in that sound module
you've got a load of different piano
sounds and you've tweaked these piano
sounds to have a certain amount of
sustain and whatever and you want to
save those settings you can use your
audio sequence or a piece of software to
record the MIDI data out of that and
then when you dump the system exclusive
data it dumps that into your computer
and then you can retrieve it back and
restore the settings on your on your
module so a nice easy way in the early
eighties to backup and restore things
amongst other things each unit that's
the whole point of system exclusive that
the stuff that that can do is exclusive
to the individual unit MIDI sounds like
it's a very useful and kind of
specialist application in in studios and
and is that was that is that what we're
talking about MIDI has been used that
long because that's what it found its
you well it started like that but no I
mean it's it's used all over the place
it was this thing that came out some
little bit of time after the MIDI spec
came out called general MIDI which kind
of standardized what you should find on
each channel so for example channel one
would be a piano channel 10 was for
drums and in the 80s and 90s people who
were playing computer games particularly
on early pcs they would have had maybe a
Sound Blaster card and then that meant
that say computer game manufacturers
could put music along with their game
where they were recording the note
information again keeping the file sizes
really small and then that would be fed
into your sound card to create whatever
fully sort of symphonic piece of music
you wanted in the background of the game
so if you had a really good sound card
but really good sounds the music on that
game might sound really good and if you
had a really cheap sound card the music
on that game could be really cheap but
the fun
was behind it was still MIDI and that
was all over the place
another thing that MIDI gets used for in
this day and age and I use it myself
live when I'm gigging is I have a foot
controller which is MIDI and then it
changes all the different sounds in my
guitar rec so if I'm on sound one and
it's nice and clean I hit and sound too
and I can play a solo or whatever and it
will change all the equipment and change
which setting they're all on it and
that's called a patch it's a very easy
way to just hit a pedal with your foot
and have all your sounds change at the
same time and that's also true for
keyboard players you know they'd be
playing on a piano sound and then get a
patch too and it suddenly becomes an
organ and it might fire off patch
changes and other people in other pieces
of equipment and that's a just a good
example of a control signal that's sent
by MIDI he'll give you a demo of how a
certain bit of MIDI works we're just
going to record something into the
computer so this is Cubase this is
version 8 which is far advanced to the
version that would have been on the
Atari ST back in the early 80s but
fundamentally it does exactly the same
thing rather than using the dx7 sounds
I'm going to use a very dated sail
that's built into Cubase so this is
controlling the computer so you can see
if I play the notes on the keyboard they
light up on the side here
let's say I'd played a note wrong heaven
forbid I did that so okay so I've got
the notes wrong there and I hit a little
fumbled bit at the end and I could
double click on this and go oh there's a
fumbled note there so I'm getting rid of
that and I can move these notes to where
they should be and then I could play
that back and it should be fixed which
still sounds bad but is her infinitely
better than it was before when it was on
the wrong note so you can see the data
is getting in and the data is being
stored in the computer as messages of
note on a note off and the color here
and represented with these bars at the
bottom as well represent the volume I
played the note on the technical side so
obviously we're seeing a bit of kind of
user end data here what does a message
look like right well we can get into
that that's funny you say that the
reason I when I first started using MIDI
I was maybe about 13 or 14 it's gone I
was entirely from the user end and then
through my career working in the studio
I was using entirely a user end and I
didn't really think about how it works I
just thought about the channels and the
messages I kind of knew what they meant
but I didn't really care about that too
much
and then something came up where I was
writing a video server application that
needed to sync up with timecode so I had
to write a timecode reader and in the
process of doing that I actually had to
start intercepting MIDI messages and
looking into what they actually
contained so I've modified that time
code reader program that I wrote so we
can actually capture into a text file
what's going on so if I just play a note
and then I let you go so we should now
just have one note on one off so if I
like this MIDI output dot txt and we can
see I played note 72 with a volume of 91
they're not actually 72 or
see one of that is in hexadecimal so
whatever they are in in decimal that's
what I played and we got a note on
signal there and another note on signal
there 0 which is denoting that it's a
note off ignore the rest of it this is
actually what's called the midi clock so
it's telling me what the the number of
the messages of C messages come in and
you want to make sure that the message
that comes in is after the previous one
and such so that's that's what that is
there the zero is the channel that it's
on which means it's actually on channel
one because I'll see 0 is channel 1 and
15 is channel 16 just to confuse
everyone so we can capture some other
things as well so if I play a note again
and then do the modulation wheel and
then back down again and then let go the
note you can now see I've got a new note
on message there and then a load of
control change information which is
increasing 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 9 it starts
skipping it gets bigger and bigger and
bigger until it reaches the top it goes
back down the other side back down to 0
again so that is literally the recording
of me pushing up the modulation wheel
and bringing it back down again and that
just makes it this is a technical term
sound Wibbly well the modulation wheel
will do whatever the sound module is is
set there's also a pitch shift wheel
which will make these you know you go up
and down in pitch or whatever so there's
all these different controls there's
panning so you can get things to go from
left to right in the speakers and all of
those things will be recorded by your
MIDI sequencer and then reproduced ok
and then you were mentioned before about
kind of controlling and synchronizing
things that to meet a really good
example of something that MIDI does well
but also shows off kind of how archaic
it is because you think with the
technology in today's time you could
send a full clock which will be hours
minutes seconds frames all in one bit of
data not literally one bit of data in
one chunk of data and it should be able
to just pick up on it in real time but
back in the day that was too much data
to send through in in one piece
so it was broke
into lots of individual pieces that were
constantly sent and and this is the this
is the way I discovered it by having to
write a time code reader so let me first
show you time code working with their so
right yeah I've just connected the MIDI
out to this and this here is connected
to my laptop which is running Reaper
which is just an audio sequencer audio
MIDI sequencer same as key base but it's
only about 16 pounds or so just getting
it so just here you can see that the
timecode is running if I stop that again
and I run my time code reader software
so what I'm going to do now is I'm going
to hit go on my laptop which will start
sending timecode via MIDI to my desktop
computer which is going to be and the
signals are going to be recorded into
the text file so we can have a look at
them so here we go play a few seconds of
this and then what I'm going to do is
jump this forward so it's a bit further
in so I'll go to there and now we're at
ten minutes and I'll record a bit of
that and I'm going to hit stop on there
and we can have a look at the text file
and see what it contains I'll give you a
breakdown of what all of these things
mean this here is the timestamp of the
MIDI signal so this here is the actual
signal that's coming in for lots of
8-bit represented in hexadecimal that
first one the f1 basically means that
it's timecode that's what that means so
we can ignore that we can also ignore
the last two because that doesn't
contain anything that's useful to
timecode so it's this second number here
which I've actually split into its
binary representation into two columns
of four and the reason I've done that is
because the first column of four says
what it is what it's representing so the
zero zero zero zero represents the
number of frames but because you've only
got four zeros to represent the number
of frames that can only be a value
between naught and fifteen and we know
that when you're dealing with frames or
other in twenty four twenty five thirty
29.97 thirty Corley thirty
c30 can't be represented in naught to 15
so the next signal there which is not
one gives you an offset so if that ends
with one which is just one so if that
becomes a one then basically you can
kind of put that on before there and
that steps it up sixteen and the same is
true for the seconds because they're up
to sixty same is true for the minutes
and the same is also true for the hours
so you've got eight bits that have to
tell you what part of the the time it is
on that time yes so so basically you you
you take the four of the first four of
the ones and zeroes and say this is this
is say hours or minutes or the offset as
I call it the offset of the hours or the
offset of the minutes so the way a
timecode signal would work is basically
you have eight different signals that
come in and they all contain a little
bit of the time so let's start with the
first signal come in that will be zero
zero zero zero which will be the number
of frames and then one which will be
called the offset for frames so the
second bunch of four will be the frame
number so let's say it was frame number
two that's going to be our one oh
because of C it's one two four eight in
the columns then your offset frames
would be zero zero zero zero but if you
wanted it to be frame 18 you'd actually
change that to a 1 so B zero zero zero
one in the offset frames which would say
are your first signal isn't 2 because
that effectively gets moved up to there
and becomes Oro 100 108 eeen
but that's sent in two separate messages
the same is true for minutes seconds
hours whatever so to send a whole time
yet requires eight messages this is a
good representation of something which
is very very solid but works really well
and clearly it works well because it is
everywhere whether you
or working with syncing up sequences in
audio or whether you're syncing up a
video server to you know a band that's
playing and you want the videos to
appear exactly the same time the band
might be playing to a click track and
the lighting desk might turn all the
lights on at that exact moment in the
show Sammy it's used to do like so and
it's very solid and it works almost
perfectly you know unless you get
someone pulls a cable out which just
happens and then it will goes wrong but
it's also very archaic you can see with
this sort of split message system that
seems to be going on you do have a MIDI
you do have things that are long
messages and short messages and it takes
up eight short messages to produce a
full piece of timecode when you hit go
initially it actually sings a long
message through which does contain the
entire timecode but I'd imagine you
can't send as many of them and it's
inefficient to send as many of them
because you you don't need to know that
once you've got a full time and you're
going you can then update the seconds
and the frames you don't really need to
update the whole time so they sending it
through in chunks so I'd imagine a lot
of it was written with you know the
computing power of the time in mind and
obviously they wanted it to be
compatible with most computers which is
why they chose it to run at one
megahertz as a musician and any other
musician should know this D minor is of
course the saddest of all keys and I
thought what is sadder then than the
piece of software that the D minor chord
is going to open now this is a example
of application of MIDI for something
it's totally useless but when I apply a
D minor are these Internet Explorer Bing
as this yours is keyboard no it's this
keyboard I borrowed from my old GCSE and
a-level physics teacher Phil Cummings
who was one of the cooler teachers at
school cause he played keyboards in a
band but there's something about a
Yamaha dx7 which just conjures up a
teaser yeah
[Music]
it's just got that sound of Oh Oh
Internet Explorer's opened again I just
I play field colleagues and internet
explorer open